you will smith look very smelt
svelte yes built tonight that's
that's what they call me in philly so
well spelt willie
wait dog you can't say that in britain i
keep forgetting it means something
different it does
you don't want a spell
that sounds like a podcast episode for
you too
so are you getting into shape for
something yeah well covet restrictions
uh i i sort of
uh ballooned a little you know dory
during that time now you posted this
picture of you this is your balloon i
forgot most of us oh most of us dream of
looking like that
that's me that's me when i'm eating
clean
that would be my after if i ever did it
[Laughter]
so this this grotesque figure of a man
i couldn't stand it anymore so but you
really went for it yeah i really went
for it i i uh so i dropped that i'm down
15 kilo from that picture right now wow
i love it in america that would get a
round of applause wouldn't it be like
here
how much is 15 kilo in pounds oh 30
pounds oh so yes
oh so yeah
now we're interested wait so you know
you you know because i was only saying
kilos because i was in europe in europe
think again
[Applause]
in america
[Applause]
[Music]
you